that's what I see from gen Z and younger
is like it's like why be a part of this
whole system because the benefits don't
seem that great I I've heard like young
kids say stuff like that but I have a
hard time believing that they actually
know because I think they're not smart
enough to think that deeply so what I
think is
[Music]
hey welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys and
the boys are back in town Joe take it
away alright so I saw this video and I
probably could play it
but we're not going to get caught by the
algorithm so I'm going to try to brief
no cursing recall what it is but the
whole point is right so I've been
noticing this thing this this like when
I opened up joombie I was um going
through this hiring phase right and I
thought it was just the Hawaii thing
where like I had about 50 people apply
and I said come on down to the interview
in about half didn't show up
so they they applied for the job they
wanted the job and half of them didn't
even show up to the interview and I was
like this is [__] weird so you
thought it was a spirit of Aloha I
thought it was I thought it was Island
time it is notorious Surfer Dudes like
yo man the when the waves are good the
waves are good I'm not coming to work
you know and then
um I was asking my friends in LA and
everywhere else and they're like no this
is a thing like this is a whole thing
like there's a lot of gen Z and younger
that's just like
you know I'm just gonna work like just
enough or maybe I don't even really want
this job that bad right and then um I
just watched this video Theo Vaughn
posted it we had this he had this dude
saying that there's like four million
like eligible working age males from
like 20 to 45. that are just choosing to
be unemployed they're not collecting
unemployment they're not just they're
just choosing not to work
and so I I was like I guess this is
happening all over the place because I
also watched another video about this is
happening in China too and it's called
the Let It Rock movement where a lot of
the youth there are just like [__] it
we're not gonna work because we see what
happened to our parents and it's like
what's the point after you work you just
like get forced to retire and then you
get used by the state and then you die
so there's this sentiment just seems to
be like common amongst gen Z and I've
seen this within family members within
people that I know their family like
there's just guys that just chill and
they just choose not to do anything so
they live with their folks or whatever
yeah until they're like lit mid to late
20s and maybe they might help contribute
like find online jobs and then like
they'll pitch into the house so they're
not like completely just sitting home
doing nothing
but they're just not they don't have a
career they're not joining the rat race
they're not joining the rat race they're
not doing things like that and so that
got me to think about like why and and
maybe I don't know we have a huge male
audience too and I'm like is everyone
working
how do they survive though like what
about food or like they just don't buy
things and they just stay at home they
don't have to pay for Mom and Dad's
fridge is always full yeah that's true
well the people that I know yeah
um
they're living at home
mid to late 20s
and they might help out their parents
they have a home-based business so
they're helping out their parents or
like let's say they're contributing like
or like they might be doing something
online like selling things and then
they'll like help pay the rent that way
so like
they're doing stuff you know what I mean
like but I feel like I could almost
relate like if I had parents that I you
know what I mean that maybe they did
really really well for themselves and I
was just always provided for you know
what I mean like I guess that could make
sense my parents were always as broke as
[__] so that's why I always ended up
having to work hard but I could also
imagine if my parents weren't broken but
how many parents did really well for
themselves to have 4 million or whatever
you know for four million people to sit
yeah I don't think it's all wealthy I
think it's like people that live minimal
so like so like like the people that I
know they're not wealthy they're just
like
you know you're just they it seems like
they you know when you're in high school
you live at home right you just stay
that lifestyle
but then now you're like mid-20s
and you're contributing to the family in
some form you might be paying partial
rent you might be kicking up money you
might be contributing to the groceries
but you're not making thousands a month
yeah you're just still living like a
high school student I mean if you can
survive but then this has happened well
I didn't know that it was happening to
guys all the way up until 45 years old I
didn't know that what is what are what
do they occupy their time with then
that's a good question that's I think
that's what everyone's wondering because
it's like
everywhere I don't know if maybe it's
just my maybe just completely anecdotal
but whenever I go to any store any store
any restaurant or like uh some a place
that's like not desirable to be worked
at like say like a Jamba Juice or
something
there's always like under always under
staff they're always like everything's
like I see posts everywhere now yeah
yeah everywhere all positions dude and
they're just like just walking walk in
um uh job interviews whatever you want
like on the side so it's like I feel
like everywhere they're just struggling
to get people that maybe they just don't
want to work these jobs maybe they think
it's like beneath them or something dude
during covid they were giving like 200
300 bonuses for people to join like Taco
Bell yeah and like they were signing
bonuses whatever
um
at least I can only speak for the people
that maybe are working that I've had
conversations with
they like they're like students or
they're like people that just like the
balance because when when I when I
started working you know I just needed
money because I was alone at like
no parents at like 20 something and at
that age I was like I need to pay rent I
gotta do this I need enough money I'm
gonna work two jobs whatever but if you
don't have to do that then their
mentality is more like oh I'll just make
a couple hundred so I can go out and
that's it do you think it's just a
comfort thing for a lot of people they
just they're comfortable in what they do
their routine they make go to work for
like a couple hours they come back and
they just chill at the house or do you
think it's like a mix of extremism like
a Stick it to the Man because they're
all also like Jaded by the system and
truly like I think that's like an excuse
people use I don't think that's real
because I actually think it could be
Mass depression yeah that four million
number is probably that but then the
people that believe more in a work-life
balance stuff I think they don't need it
so like so think that I choose it but
but they're also like capable or have a
career before and just shows like yeah
like imagine you're a college student
imagine you're an unemployed college
degree person right
like you want a job that's like
respectable corporate whatever you're
not gonna go for a blue collar job
you're like I had to do that because
when I graduated it was during the
recession so then I had a degree but I
went straight into shipping because I
couldn't find a job that you can't
[__] have a Humanities degree and
then work
there's not much jobs for that or like a
sociology degree or whatever I had a
psychology degree there's not many jobs
with a bachelor's you can get with a
psychology degree and then so all these
people who believe that maybe they
should have a higher pay because of what
they had they don't want these jobs that
are available so now we have a lot of
jobs that are like hey Starbucks is open
whatever's open right but now you have
all these people that feel overqualified
that's never worked a day in their life
that think that they should go work for
Google or whatever well they also well
plus a lot of those tech jobs are a
[__] joke I mean did we not just see
that with Twitter Elon fired half of
them and Twitter's working totally fine
everyone's like Twitter's dead like next
Monday Twitter is completely dead you'll
see and then like cut a lot of fat out
of that yeah and then you guys saw that
Tick Tock I'm sure of like that chick
who worked at Twitter and she's like
getting my wine from like you know I'm
having a wine party up here and she's
like okay I have meetings in the
afternoon it's like oh it's like the
biggest eye roll ever of like a a
Silicon Valley job quote unquote
um but then yeah like Joe's talking
about I think social media has helped to
make a lot of these jobs look even more
undesirable like there's this like
beneath me quality to a lot of that [__]
like you were talking about Nick like
Jamba Juice not desirable right but why
you're it's a you're you're working
that's respectable yeah but uh those
things have been separated from each
other it's like the fact that you're
working and the fact that that's
honorable has been separated from each
other because it's like oh no that's a
dumpster job that's a shitty I don't
want a basic job exactly and then and
then couple that with like social media
like remember that guy who's on The
Cosby Show and they they caught him like
they caught him
you're bagging groceries at Trader Joe's
yeah yeah that was really messed up
making fun of him and [__] and so he had
to quit and it's like dude that like
he's working for his family that's
[__] up now like that's beneath you no
like is that really what's going on I
think that's the biggest issue is that
uh there's like normal
jobs like working class jobs that no one
wants because they feel like it's
socially wrong and you're like a loser
you're a loser but then I'm like we need
we need people to do all these jobs
because they're like the normal jobs
that people need to work in order for
the society to function we need guys to
[__] rig the lines we need guys to
work the stewards we need guys to like
we need all that [__] like what started
that though like what started everybody
calling snobbery and classes social
media dude there's a huge amount of
classes Asian parents and I think covet
too I think it's like a big Whirlwind of
like no one's working and they're like
okay I can get used to this and then
social everyone's on their phone on
social media and so now that messaging
is spread faster than ever because I
wonder if kids today or at least younger
people still see that like because when
I was like 18 19 I worked at the mall
everybody was really cool and there was
no feeling of like we're losers yeah and
people that were at the mall that were
just customers never look looked at
anybody like oh you work at Finish Line
what a loser like yeah it was cool like
it was different if you're 18 or 19 and
you're working
it's like oh you're a go-getter like
regardless of your job if you're like 35
or 40 and you're like you know bagging
groceries you know I can understand that
the world we live in will look at that
and be like hey you're kind of a loser
you didn't do [__] for the last life I
mean we we still had we had co-workers
that were that old and we had people at
Starbucks that were in their 30s and the
cool thing about them was wow they must
be getting tons of benefits by now yeah
he bought an S2000 with saving up like
there was I don't I don't know if kids
today still think like I have no idea
but we all thought yeah I think John
butchers is just looking for 18 or 19
year olds yeah they're just nowhere to
be found but yeah I even think like a
lot of the 18 19 year olds nowadays like
they don't work
like a lot of like a lot of the students
that come in our I get surprised when I
see that some people don't even want to
drive oh bro that's a whole conversation
you know that's crazy they're like I
want to get a license people drive me
around we have this 16 year old at the
gym and he goes telling me he goes I got
my license I'm one of the only kids in
my school that have a license that are
my age like no but I kind of get it
because they could Uber right but then
also that should cost money if you can
think like it's like why would I want to
add 500 a month like I think people are
questioning consumerism and I think when
you question the when because younger
kids now they see like the dark side of
materialism consumerism and capitalism
right it's like you work work work and
you buy all this [__] for what because
they probably saw their parents go into
debt spiraling just buying all this [__]
so they see that and they're probably
like well I don't want to [__] do
that why would I want to do that and now
there's this whole movement on
minimalism and all these other things
and living below tiny houses tiny houses
whatever right so it might be just all
these different things just questioning
like the normal middle class keeping up
with the Joneses lifestyle working for a
corporation doing the nine to five and
also there's this whole movement of like
oh pursue your dreams your work should
be like be your place of happiness and
motivation and all that and it's like
what about just normal jobs of like
working class men or whatever and I feel
like those jobs disappeared because also
a lot of people don't want them or they
can't or they want to move away like
whenever a society gets Rich they go
what do they do like they want to send
their kids off to college right even
Working Class People want to send their
kids off to college and then they they
want them to become White Collar they
don't want them working in like
construction and stuff just like them so
I think as as this moves forward then
it's like who's gonna do those jobs do
you think we're this is just like a
situation of like back in my day because
like that's what I feel like it's a
little bit of that because I think
generationally right like like you look
at how our parents grow up or what their
story was to come to this country or
what the jobs that they used to do
versus like what we do now our
generation you have you have kids I
think everyone's just getting a little
softer and there's less things to worry
about me well I think one one is the
survival aspect right like most of the
Immigrant mentality is I just need to
[__] eat because I couldn't eat at
home or whatever right so then now you
have abundance that's the second stage
now you need meaning and purpose and
work so that's our that's our generation
that's our generation because we were
just talking about I don't want to be a
doctor I want to do something that I
like an art or whatever that I care
about not because I'm forced to be a
doctor to pay for my bills or whatever
it is right that's the millennial
version right it is the millennial and
then maybe the next stage is what's the
point of it all anyway what's the point
of doing all this [__] buying all this
[__] why like why even start a family
like I'm gonna set my kids up to be in
the system where they're gonna be
economic slaves like what's the point
and I think that's what I see from gen Z
and younger is like it's like why be a
part of this whole system because the
benefits don't seem that great I I've
heard like young kids say stuff like
that but I have a hard time believing
that they actually know because I think
they're not smart enough to think that
deeply so what I think you kind of have
to be there because you have to you have
to have been through some [__] to really
know what everything is what that means
if you haven't been through some [__]
it's just big vocabulary words right so
I'm like I hear like some young kids say
stuff like that but what it feels like
to me and I could be completely wrong it
feels like they're really just depressed
and this is the messaging that fits how
they feel because in all of biology
organisms Thrive when there's growth in
their life and stability yeah so
regardless if you're a postman that
makes your rounds or if you're a
billionaire but if each day you can see
yourself stacking chips that's when the
organism is the most thriving so for a
fact that people that are like I'm just
not gonna do anything that to me is like
oh this organism is not good it's going
against your human nature yeah you're
going against your DNA so you're just
now regurgitating words to explain their
behavior but I actually think you're not
really about this yeah because you'll
find growth somewhere else I think
that's that's why I see that as an
excuse too I'm like you're just trying
to find the narrative that justifies how
lazy you are or some [__] I was in a a
lift last night not Uber
um and this this chick was driving and
she was telling me about how she just
feels like she can't keep up because
she's paying three G's a month for like
1400 square feet you know in like
California and the gas just constantly
goes up and you know the even the amount
that she gets for ride sharing is going
down and there's days where she doesn't
make any [__] money and then there's
maybe one random day where she makes
like a decent amount of money that
catches her up but she always feels like
she's on that thin line and that's I
think what's going on with a lot of
people too it's like so she's working
there's somebody sitting at home not
working and they're both basically
seeing the same thing which is at the
end of the day where is my progress like
where where really is it I'm like I lose
all my money every month anyway because
the cost of living is so [__] high
and look at you know the rate of
inflation with the rate of wages in
America is a [__] joke right like we
can't even catch up it used to be you
know you could have a fan family so like
you know Bart and Geo
um Bart could just support the family
like with his job but now it's got to be
both people working for something at the
same time because you know we're not
represented right like the system's not
for us it's it's for yeah I emphasize
working working class families because
back in the day working class families
you could have a a single
earner like the father who worked at the
factory and they were able to carve out
a little decent living I could buy a
house exactly and now like a working
class family might have to become
roommates with another working class
family and jam-packed that house exactly
so they can pay the rent in La which is
now the average Inc house is is gonna
cost eight hundred thousand dollars at
five percent dude if yeah give me a
break they're pricing everybody out yeah
so and let's say you're you're a working
class family and you're making 30 to 50
000 a year how the [__] are you gonna
afford a house payment let alone a car
payment and then like it just doesn't
make the math doesn't make anything
you're a rent slave you're a wage
exactly so I can totally see why the
youth seeing that and going what's the
point what's the [__] point and then
so maybe I'll just rent a room and and
because that's affordable maybe I can
make a thousand bucks a month because
that's affordable and then I can just
ride a bike everywhere
and then I won't get a girlfriend and a
family because that's expensive and then
now everything is like because because
not it's not just happening in the
States this is happening everywhere in
first First World countries because even
in Japan like the the birth rate is low
the marriage rate all that stuff is low
because everyone has the same mentality
of like I'm just gonna work till I die
what's the point dude I was listening to
Jeff Bezos recently and he was saying he
was saying um
he's like yeah you know I think the
economy is about to get pretty bad so
like families out there you should
probably start saving up all right see
ya
so tell that to the chick in the in the
lift yesterday you know like hey these
people can't relate at all they have no
[__] idea but that shit's still
industrious though she's out driving and
having a job she's different than the
person that's staying at home well you
know why she's doing it she's doing it
for her family that's the tip she's
doing it for the most Primal reason that
everyone out there I think is doing it
in this family preservation that's why I
believe that survival gets people to go
oh I need to work right but then right
the people that don't they don't need to
is what I'm saying so that means it's
got to get worse before you can get
better I think I mean that's
historically what they say is that
that's when the you know the best
civilizations are born but I still think
like that's why I give it up to the
previous generation for the fact that
like there was no social media so nobody
was there to hear your grievances all
you could do is this yeah and that's
yeah nobody gives a [__] [__] how you
feel it was but also when you when you
worked and you saved your money you saw
more of it at the end of the day that's
true they weren't printing your money
out of existence yes they were moving
off of the gold standard slowly turning
up the heat on the Frog right but but it
was at least you could make a living for
yourself a carve out a living for
yourself but I would argue that that was
Golden Age America after World War II I
would say previous to that Great
Depression like eras of just indentured
servitude and just people coming in and
working and they don't have anything
that's been a pretty
big part of the history here and we're I
think we're going back to that where
people are just working and working and
they're just debt slaves so like I can
see why it's at this point where hey if
I can eat food and sleep in a
comfortable bed I'm just gonna be on my
phone all day 100 yeah and I get that I
really get that mentality because
dopamine I have a lot of fun in my work
but
not everyone can have the same I like
like work like I don't know if I can
have that same fun
doing the normal labor jobs that you
can't romanticize you can't romanticize
that [__] it's just normal honest work
that's all it is so it's like but at
least you could at least when you're
doing the normalized work before right
you're saving up enough to afford a home
but now they're pricing you out of the
market so bad you have to compete with
other countries even to get a house now
you can't even just they they [__] up
our system so much that you you can't
have faith in it at all so you're not
what are you working towards it's like
every every step you take towards
forwards you're on an escalator moving
backwards and people and this is it's
showing up now in the real world and I
think the one thing that we didn't talk
about that's like affecting men
specifically is only fans like that [__]
I think ruins and pornography yeah like
for real I agree
punchline
no that [__] is I think that's for real
because like especially with men like
there's all these studies coming out
about how like whenever you jerk off
like sexual dopamine release is like way
stronger than anything else like any
other dopamine release you get so like
these guys could just watch porn beat
off get their hit and be like Oh I'm
good for another like 15-20 minutes and
then they're back on it again start
beating their dicks and they that was me
in college I couldn't get any homework
done because I kept jacking off and
going to sleep and that [__] with your
reward system how you I do think we have
a lot of misplaced dopamine yeah these
days because they like don't talk like
the hard honest word you're supposed to
get the dopamine from the actual work do
a good day's work like like yeah actual
like going oh [__] I was very productive
epic regardless of what the subject
matter is I did this much I get a
dopamine hit but I think now it's like
everything has to be so concentrated and
it has to be like am Alex hermosi
dropped some [__] bars on me and I'm
like whoa crazy I didn't get more I
didn't get more of that first back then
that amount of dopamine was just like
eight hours of heart whether it's
cutting a tree or some [__] like that
but all of our dopamine is misplaced
everywhere I think so and it's so hard
to come back from that dude especially
with social media dude like with the
tick like The Tick Tock algorithm was so
good I totally understand why people are
just like constant because it's it's
you're just watching everything you see
all this new funny stuff on Tick Tock
constantly and it never stops like my
wife sometimes I'm like before bed I'm
like just five more minutes yeah yeah
and then I go oh [__] is an hour oh [__]
bro I do understand what you're saying
though it's it is the we are seeing the
effects of the economy developing
obtusly where it's like oh [__] money
went this way work didn't yeah and
that's what we get for voting that way
that's exactly it oh yeah yeah exactly
and continuing no people a little bit
more sad now after this hey look people
wonder why I'm in crypto but this is
exactly why I don't believe in our
system period I'm down to go with a
system where we're still working out the
Kinks and [__] and yes there's tons of
scams in that in the system just like
our system but at least there's an end
goal in mind which is sovereignty right
actually having your money work for you
hopefully at some point gets it [__]
worked out right in our lifetime please
yeah oh God please
no but then and real quick to just wrap
up my story with the Lyft driver so as
she dropped me off it was it was such a
great conversation she was really
awesome but then she's like
um you know like it'd be awesome if you
tip me because all the tips just go
directly towards me and I was like oh I
don't tip
[Laughter]
foreign